llaman los dragones dorados son enormes
máquinas que tragan los ríos colombianos
en busca de oro
según las autoridades la minería ilegal
financia grupos del crimen organizado
algo que contradice en sus operadores
son Mineros de la zona donde llevan años
haciendo la actividad
que no se le esconden a nadie la presión
de las fuerzas de seguridad del gobierno
contra este tipo de actividad hizo que
cientos de Mineros protagonizaran
manifestaciones y bloqueos de carreteras
a principios de marzo que nosotros
estamos dispuestos una formalización
estamos siendo muy estigmatizados hemos
tenido mucha presencia militar con que
corremos mucho riesgo que nos vayan a
quemar la draga o que nos capturen lo
cierto Es que la minería mueve la
economía de la zona donde opera por lo
que la guerra contra la búsqueda de oro
afecta a los residentes locales de la
minería Nosotros siempre acá todo lo que
vendemos son a ellos a los mineros
vienen acá los compran el pescado la
yuca leen la tienda ese los compran las
cosas todo lo compran acá el mayor
problema de la minería ilegal es la
contaminación del medio ambiente en el
proceso para sacar oro las dragas
desvían fondos aluviales y contaminan
las aguas de los ríos con mercurio un
componente necesario para separar el
mineral de las rocas el 65% de la
producción de oro en los ríos
colombianos es ilegal según datos de la
oficina contra el delito y la droga de
la ONU